trailer Matt wall show Elon Musk earns
the Wrath of the left once again for
mocking preferred pronoun nonsense but
mockery and Scorn is exactly what
preferred pronouns deserve also MSNBC
declares that Brittany greiner's
experience proves that black women are
oppressed but it doesn't approve
actually the opposite of that meanwhile
Global weapons trafficker Victor bout
gives his first interview after being
traded back to Russia and appears to
love America more than the woman we
traded for plus Dr fauci speaks out
about the danger children might pose to
their grandparents this holiday season a
school board overwhelmingly votes
against a candidate for school board
president based on the fact that he's a
CIS white male and in our daily
cancellation Olive Garden manager is
fired after going nuclear on employees
who call out of work I'm on the manager
side on this one maybe not surprisingly
all of that and more today on the Matt
Walsh show
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
Roe v Wade has been overturned and this
battle is now finally leaving D.C and
going to the Grassroots no group in
America is better positioned than 40
Days for life with about 1 million
Volunteers in a thousand cities 40 Days
for life holds peaceful vigils outside
abortion facilities they have a larger
presence in blue states with California
being their largest state some former
abortion facility directors say that
these vigils can cause the abortion
no-show rate to go as high as 75 which
is obviously detrimental to their
abortion business to say the least these
law-abiding vigils have closed many
abortion businesses in America and
nearly half of those closed abortion
facilities were in Liberal cities where
abortion will remain legal including
closures in San Francisco Chicago and
Seattle 40 Days for life is effectively
changing hearts and Minds in the
Grassroots to end abortion you can check
out their locations podcasts and free
magazine at 40 daysforlife.com and it's
so crucial that you do because this
fight for life is far from over and
you've got to get invested in order to
do that go to 40daysforlife.com
over the weekend Elon Musk appeared on
stage with Dave Chappelle at a show in
San Francisco now um I don't know for
sure what's what sort of reception musk
was expecting but he's obviously a smart
guy so I'm assuming he was not surprised
by the reaction he actually received
which uh sounded like this
is going to make some noise for the
richest man in the world
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
damn
[Applause]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
we're expecting this will ya
[Applause]
it sounds like some of them people you
fired are in the audience
so they don't seem to like him very much
and if we were to watch the rest of that
clip we would hear a musk have a short
exchange with Chappelle before shouting
the famous Chappelle Show line
um rich and walking off the stage which
is uh certainly one way to handle this
kind of situation and not a bad way
either needless to say there are you
know a few honors in life greater than
being booed by a crowd of low IQ San
franciscans question though is whether
anyone in that crowd knew why they were
booing now they're they're vaguely aware
that Elon Musk is one of the guys
they're supposed to hate but if you were
to stop them and conduct a poll maybe as
they left the stadium and uh and said
hey what was that all about why why do
you guys hate them would they be able to
explain their hatred that seems pretty
unlikely
they would not be able to articulate why
they hate Elon Musk because their hatred
is a reflex it's a result of cultural
conditioning it's a sort of a tribal
response against an outsider all they
know is that musk has taken positions
and conveyed ideas that do not follow
the leftist Orthodoxy he's a mainstream
figure who has gone off script and not
even that far off script I mean he he
could not by any measure be credibly
described as right wing even if the
media does describe him that way he's
certainly not but any amount of
improvisation any attempt to think for
oneself
especially by mainstream figure is
apostasy
in the minds of many people in the
culture
musk would continue Off Script over the
weekend tweeting on early Sunday morning
he said he tweeted this my pronouns are
prosecute slash fauci now this was a
fascinating experiment in some ways
because the left had to choose whether
to be primarily angry that he was
mocking the high priest fauci
or that he was mocking LGBT Dogma now
they could be angry about both of course
they can be angry about many things all
at once it's perhaps their only skill
juggling multiple outrages but
the ensuing outrage cycle would have to
revolve primarily around one or the
other because that's the way outrage
Cycles work and it's no surprise that
the LGBT desecration is What attracted
the most higher because on the left you
know fauci is a high priest but LGBT
people are deities so even he must take
a back seat in this kind of situation
there are many Furious responses uh you
know accusing musk of transphobia and
homophobia and so on because he was
making fun of the pronoun stuff one of
the responses Drew an additional uh
reply from musk himself former astronaut
Scott Kelly posted quote Elon please
don't Mock and promote hate toward
already marginalized and at-risk of
violence members of the lgbtq plus
Community they're they are real people
with real feelings furthermore Dr fauci
is a dedicated public servant whose sole
motivation was saving lives
and to that musk replied quote I
strongly disagree forcing your pronouns
upon others when they didn't ask and
implicitly ostracizing those who don't
is neither good nor kind to anyone as
for fauci he lied to Congress and funded
gain of function research that killed
millions of people not awesome in my
opinion
not awesome indeed as for the rest of
this uh I think there are two important
points as we're having another uh
National discourse on pronouns first
contrary to Scott Kelly's claims
LGBT people are not in the slightest bit
marginalized they are in fact the least
marginalized people
in the history of the human race I don't
think that there's ever been a
demographic a
group of people a quote-unquote
community that has been less
marginalized than LGBT people in modern
America
okay and I can justify that based on the
fact that when you when you compare
their percentages in the population to
their influence and their representation
and the culture and the amount of
over-the-top adulation and worship they
receive you quickly see that they belong
to a very unique category entire months
on the calendar are devoted to
celebrating them when's the last time a
marginalized group in society had a
month to themselves not just a month not
just one month but months and then weeks
after that in multiple days
they have their own Flags which are
draped all over Schools and Government
buildings
every major corporation in the country
bows at their feet celebrities go out of
their way to identify themselves as
members of this club people are
desperate to be a part
of this marginalized community
so-called
and it's not because everyone likes to
be marginalized that's that's not the
case like throughout history what you
find is is an in actual when it comes to
actually oppressed and marginalized
groups in history
um if anything people are are you know
uh trying to present themselves as
though they're not a part of that group
even if they are because they don't want
to be marginalized and oppressed
so why is everyone clamoring to be a
part of this marginalized Group is
because everyone knows that the
marginalization claim is total nonsense
second Elon Musk is right
to mock the pronoun thing
this is what we need people in the
mainstream to do that's what we all need
to be doing okay arguing against it is
fine
explaining your arguments about why you
disagree with the pronoun stuff but
heaping pure mockery and Scorn on the
entire ritual is even better
because that's what all this is the
exchanging of pronouns the listing of
pronouns it is a ritual it's a religious
right
it is a symbolic gesture meant to Signal
an individual's affirmation and Ascent
to LGBT Dogma
and it's spreading everywhere this is
not just a routine relegated to Twitter
bios anymore schools and workplaces
increasingly expect and demand
participation in the Liturgy of pronouns
and they usually give reasons like
tolerance and professionalism to justify
the intrusion of preferred pronouns in
deep spaces CBS News outlined the case
in a recent article titled everything
you need to know about gender pronouns
at work
and it begins by saying it is
increasingly common for Professionals of
all Stripes to include a line in their
digital signatures below their name or
title indicating what gender pronouns
they use that may read something like
she her hers or they them theirs and
specifics on how an individual wants to
be addressed other than by their name
for some people who are gender
non-binary or transgender being
misgendered can cause discomfort and
anxiety quote being misgendered is a
dehumanizing experience it's being
reminded again and again that you don't
exist as your gender in other people's
eyes said Kami cites churner a
co-founder of a tutoring Cooperative who
uses the pronouns they them Advocates
stress how important it is that
companies develop policies around
personal pronoun use as part of their
inclusion efforts in part so lgbtq
people feel safe at work more simply
it's a matter of respecting everyone in
the workplace
this of course is nonsense this is not
inclusion this is not respect this is
forced conversion
it is the leftist version of if you can
imagine a secular school or workplace
strongly encouraging students and
employees to do the sign of the cross
periodically throughout the day
this would not be a way of including
Catholics
okay Catholics are already free to do
the sign of the cross whenever they want
pressuring others to engage in a
symbolic ritual act which signals Ascent
to a belief system they don't even hold
is not tolerance it is again
indoctrination
and in the case of the sign of the cross
such a policy would be considered wildly
illegal and any secular school or
workplace that initiated it would be
sued into Oblivion
pronouns are not treated the same why
because they are uh a symbol of the LGBT
religion which is now our unofficial and
maybe eventually official state religion
this is why it's so necessary that we
resist the pronoun garbage
and mock it ruthlessly whenever we get
the opportunity
people who demand that you adopt their
belief system
deserve nothing but scorn and there is
no neutral way to look at any of this
you know the very concept of an
individual having a pronoun these are my
pronouns what are your pronouns it's
it's nonsensical
because in reality nobody has pronouns
you can't have a pronoun anymore you can
have a preposition or an adverb the
concept doesn't make any sense
pronouns are not things that you can own
they're not like accessories they are
parts of speech
that's it you don't get to customize
them
so when someone asks you what your
pronouns are
any attempt to sincerely answer the
question is a concession that the
question makes sense
it concedes that each individual gets to
take possession of their own pronoun
which are dependent on their
self-perception so if you uh if you're a
man
and somebody asks what your pronouns are
and you think that you're you know
you're not participating in the game if
you just tell them well my pronouns are
he him
well you actually are taking part in the
game because you're not actually in this
Exchange
the way the symbolism Works you're not
actually declaring yourself to be a man
you're rather declaring that you
perceive yourself to be a man
as if there's some sort of meaningful or
relative or relevant or or definitional
distinction between what you are and
what you perceive yourself to be
you you are playing the game
whether you mean to or not it's really
no different than it's when someone says
what are your pronouns what they really
ask you what gender do you perceive
yourself to be that's what the question
is
but if you just say man then again
you're going along with it
the actual answer you want to give is
like what do you mean perceive myself I
am a man that's that's it that's what I
am it's not about what I perceive myself
to be it's just simply what I am
so if I reject the framing of that
question
when it comes to pronouns the
appropriate response then to the
question of what are your pronouns must
be something along the lines of
that question makes no sense leave me
the hell alone
or you can cut out the first sentence
and just go right to the second either
option works or come up with your own
variation
as long as it's something that
communicates your refusal to surrender
to this madness
and your contempt for the fact that it's
being pushed on you
to begin with
now let's get to our five headlines
if you're listening to this show odds
are that you put a lot of stock into how
you raise your kids you understand that
your children look to you to Define
their values and their perspectives of
the world that's why it's extremely
important that you have a will in place
a will also determines how your
financial assets are dispersed as well
as your personal property it lays out
your health care power of attorney to
ensure that your end of life decisions
are carried out if you're just starting
out you don't have thousands of dollars
to spend on an attorney but you want to
make sure your savings your belongings
and your family are all protected you
have to create your will at epicwill.com
today epic Will's early estate plans
started just 119 and you can save 10
percent when you use promo code Walsh go
to epicwill.com is promo code Walsh to
save 10 on Epic Wheels complete will
package that's epicwill.com promo code
Walsh
well I gotta start here because we just
knew that this was coming
um we we knew it was it was it was
probably not only is it coming but it's
probably going to come from MSNBC and it
did so here's the uh the headline
over the weekend Brittany Greiner is
finally freed but her Peril is that of
black women in America
okay now reading a little bit from this
article on MSNBC
says when tennis star Serena Williams
gave birth to her daughter in 2017 she
nearly died because doctors did not
believe her when she cried out in pain
it turns out Williams the most famous
athlete the world's most famous athlete
it says which I don't think that's true
at all that Serena Williams is the
world's most famous athlete but whatever
was uh suffering from blood clots in her
lungs it would be hours before doctors
agreed to do a CAT scan and rush to
break up the clotting before it reached
her heart despite all of her Prestige
and achievements Williams was at the
mercy of a medical system that is
uniquely fatal for black women the state
of powerlessness black women including
Serena Williams are relegated to is a
phenomenon sociologist and author Tracy
McMillan cotton discussed in her Memoir
thick and other essays it supersedes
even the most powerful status cultures
in all of neoliberal capitalism wealth
and fame cotton wrote the same can be
said for American basketball player
Brittany Greiner who has been sitting in
a Russian prison cell for over five
months for carrying 0.7 ounces of
cannabis oil in her luggage
cannabis from a vape cartridge which her
lawyer said she only brought to Russia
by accident
uh Griner the two-time Olympic gold
medalist WNBA Champion pleaded guilty to
drug charges the result of which could
put her behind bars for up to 10 years
now
as I'm reading this you're picking up
with the fact that this is a little bit
this is not exactly up to date
so this was
written before she was released it was
written back in the summer
and then after she's released released
it's repackaged and and published again
what makes that so funny is that the the
manner and circumstances of her release
disprove the thesis of the article
so rather than putting an update and
saying well forget about all this
nonsense we were actually wrong about
this
uh rather than doing that they're just
they're just putting it out again
reasserting it
they were trying to position what's
happening Brittany Greiner as somehow
you know it's it's uh she's being
uniquely victimized in some way because
she's a black woman
and yeah this again is written in July
and then you fast forward a few months
and they they they trade the most
notorious Global arms dealer in the
world just for her
and they've got they got three people
they could conceivably choose between
her and then two white men and they
choose and they they trade just for her
and leave the other two
and rather than the media like
reassessing their uh
you know claims that she was being
uniquely victimized because she was
black woman rather than doing that they
just go ahead and reassert it because it
doesn't matter
as always it's a it's an unfalsifiable
Theory and no matter what have just like
climate change no matter what actually
happens it proves whatever they already
believed
it's interesting too starting with this
uh anecdote about Serena Williams and
you know as always the the focus on
identity politics only ensures that you
miss the point
entirely
so the issue with Serena Williams
apparently is that she was in pain and
the doctors I guess weren't taking the
pain seriously and then uh and that
could have been very very bad
um because they they weren't taking it
seriously enough and it turns out she
had a blood clot in her lungs which is a
very bad situation
but they're they're trying to connect
this to the fact that she's a black
woman
um which just
it prevents the conversation from
reaching any useful conclusions at all
because of course this is an issue that
happens to anyone potentially when
they're in the hospital I went to and
this wasn't a potentially
life-threatening situation but when I
busted my achilles I went to the I went
to the hospital to the emergency room
totally busted Achilles and I go there
and uh they tell me that it's just a
strain and uh and then I ask you know
it's the first time I left I've actually
asked for for pain medication they
wouldn't give it to me they gave me they
said we'll just take some Tylenol go
home and take some time I'll put some
ice on it a week later I go to a
specialist and they say oh yeah it's not
a strain it's completely busted you're
yeah so suffering and a lot of pain for
a week because of this and now I'm a
white man so I didn't have the the
marginalized identity to explain this
and so how do you explain it well
you know from from the from the uh the
perspective of the medical staff
one thing is that they've got a lot of
people coming in all the time and
sometimes they are exaggerating their
pains and sometimes they're doing that
because they want the drugs and all that
so they're trying to balance these
things
doesn't make it okay but it just means
that again when you're trying to explain
everything through identity politics it
makes you miss it's a very it's a very
it's very narrow lens and you're gonna
miss a lot of the picture
um back to the Brittany Greiner trade
meanwhile representative Sheila Jackson
Lee
you know uh because so Democrats they've
spent time over the weekend doing some
of the Sunday shows and some of the
cable news shows trying to explain why
this was a good trade and here was
Sheila Jackson Lee's attempt
as the facts would tell them he was
sentenced to 25 years he saved served 11
to 16 years I don't know they can't
remember the exact number
but in actuality
um his weapons might have been used to
kill Americans but he has not killed
Americans I'm not saying he's not a
nasty bad guy
but I will tell you that I believe that
Americans should know that the
sovereignty of their Nation will always
be behind them and they'll never be
forgotten
right Leicester Paul Whalen or Mark
vogelman who's still still sitting in a
prison cell uh his weapons were used to
kill Americans but he didn't kill them
I I wondered I don't I don't have any
Clips to back this up but I'm because I
haven't looked it up but I'm gonna I'm
gonna go out on a limb here wild crazy
limb and I'm gonna say that um
Sheila Jackson Lee
like every other Democrat on the
national stage has multiple times in her
career blamed you know the NRA
uh gun rights advocates
for mass shootings
that they had no direct tie to
whatsoever
so if you advocate
for legal gun ownership and then a mass
shooting happens then it's effectively
like you killed those people
and yet if you're Victor about and you
actually give the weapons to the bad
guys
who are telling you hey I want to go
kill Americans with this and you sell
them weapons and then they go kill them
let's say you didn't kill them so it's
not it's not quite as bad
speaking of Victor about he himself uh
again the the the
arms trafficker
he did his first interview where he was
surprisingly
sympathetic to the United States and um
this whole clip has been making the
rounds online let's watch a little bit
of it
do you hate America no you know in fact
unnoving many names I figure out who's
sharing way more common
America is
very much similar look it's the same
size if they have a it's the same kind
of this and when you talk to them there
is nothing there even to beef about we
are naturally
you know born not to be enemies and
whenever there's conflict it's Elites
you know every you know American I met
in a prison who is from rural area
was very easy to deal with
she has no problem with Russia and he
was curious about Russia despite all
propaganda they're losing their
Christian values they're losing their
families they're losing literally their
countries
it's not anymore the same country we
knew America who used to be a model for
entire world and lead and be an example
you know like they say a shiny Town
under you know sparkling town on a hill
and this is of course pity
it was a strong
country who was really a you know
industrial mind you know this one and
look for 30 40 years
the industrialization drug problem crime
waves
you can understand and I feel more
empathy to American of the best
experience than I would feel any hate
what would you consider as the most
important event of the years
that you have spent in prison
ah which events are international well
it doesn't matter all right maybe
International 2014.
it is quite
quite quite sad that uh the guy
the international
arm Smuggler
who we traded back to Russia
appears based on what he said to love
America more than the woman we traded
for
okay like those are sentiments that
you're never going to hear from Brittany
Greiner she wouldn't even be able to
express it
both because she lacks the articulation
required but also because she just
doesn't she doesn't see America though
she hates America she really does
when you refuse to when you say I'm not
gonna go out into the court while the
national anthem was played that is I
mean that can only be driven by pure
scorn and resentment for your home
country
you would never hear that from Brittany
Greiner
instead we hear from the from the
Russian guy that were trading the guys
were trading back to Russia
so we're sending away the person who
loves America more and bringing in the
person who hates America now now look uh
what you're hearing there like there's a
reason why they did the interview in
English right is this is this perhaps a
ploy on the part of Russia is that is
that an you know a part of this that's
probably the case
but even so
it's still quite sad that the woman
we're bringing in would never say
anything like that
and everything he said is
is true
whether he really believes any of that I
have no idea but what he said is true
all right
uh Dr fauci over the week was asked
about the dangers
posed by as we get into the holidays and
people are worried about you know the
holidays and and they're going to be
around their families it's a very
terrifying Prospect
so he's asked about the dangerous posed
by unvaccinated
grandchildren listen to this
and with the holidays approaching we've
had lots of questions about safety of
gathering with friends and family
especially if loved ones haven't been
vaccinated so Lucy from Maine s since
we've been vaccinated how dangerous is
it to be near our grandchildren they
have not been vaccinated Beyond what's
required in the schools right well
vaccination again is the answer so if
you want to protect your grandchildren
and vice versa even though the
grandchildren are not required to get
vaccinated if they are within the age
which is now six months or older I would
encourage their family so if you're the
grandparent I would encourage my child
who is the parent of my grandchildren to
get their children vaccinated
now uh needless to say I guess maybe
it's not needless to say it should be
but if you're bringing your kids in to
get vaccinated you're just a
a maniac especially at this point
you know there's there is there was
never any good reason for it
especially not now
um
although
I also have to say and I listened to
that to that and and we hear from Lucy
whoever that is that says that what
danger what danger is posed by how
dangerous is it to be around our
grandchildren and look I know this does
not apply to all older people I I
realize that
but speaking of very general terms here
okay
for me this speaks to one of the saddest
things about the covet panic
uh one of the one of the saddest things
one of the most pathetic saddest and
disgraceful things it was not just that
children were kept away from their
grandparents
okay that was disgraceful
but also and this is the part that
people don't like to talk about quite as
much
um but also that so many grandparents
went along with it and wanted it
know pushed it pushed this they pushed
this separation they they wanted that
we heard many stories about this we all
know like anecdotally you know we hear
stories from people in their own lives
and you know their heads had
grandparents I don't want to be around
anyone in the family who's not
vaccinated
it's just it it
it's absolutely pathetic
and I would have hoped you know before
all this happened
I would have thought
that especially when they started when
they started telling us that you know
kids are not allowed to be around their
grandparents
I thought there would be an uprising of
grandparents other grandparents would be
out in the lead of this thing
and say are you kidding me to try to
keep me away from my grandkids no way
you know I've lived a long life I've
lived a good life I I don't you know
I've only got so much time left in the
first place now you're trying to you
know Rob my my final days my final years
of you know the experience of being
around my my kids I would rather be I
thought we would have
millions of grandparents saying I would
rather be dead than be isolated from my
from my family from my grandchildren yes
I will risk my life my life to see my
grandchild if that's what you're telling
me it is which it isn't
because because kids were
they were never at a high risk of
Contracting covet also never had a high
risk of spreading it
so it's never like you're risking your
life to see your grandchildren
but I would have thought there'd be
millions of grandparents that would say
I'm willing to risk my life to see them
even if that's what it is I don't
believe your your hysterical propaganda
but I also don't care about it because
if it's true you know what I'll take
that risk
yeah I will risk my life just to spend a
couple hours around my grade I thought
this was and yes there there's certainly
some grandparents that that was their
view of things and uh when when the
uprising against the covid
you know the the oppression in the name
of Cove it happened there are many older
people that were a part of it but I'm
I'm again talking in general terms
there's also a
very common sentiment that we just heard
from you know like we just heard from
Sally is it dangerous to be around my
grandkids my God
for the sake of extending a life that
you've already not that your you know
life is less meaningful now just because
you're older certainly not the case but
you have lived
a long life and for the and for the ex
for the sake of extending it
you know isolate yourself from your
family you see your grandchildren is
dangerous to you
what kind of life is that
and after all this time to still have
that attitude
I just can't even imagine that I can't
imagine being older you know whatever
being in your 70s or something or 80s
and you've been isolated you've isolated
yourself for two years and you're still
not sick of it
there's just something uh there's
something very very
sick about that I don't mean physically
sick I mean spiritually mentally
all right this is from the Washington
examiner the school board in
Pennsylvania had voted eight to one this
week against allowing one of their
colleagues Gregory Goliath uh
the Delia I guess to become the
president of the board because he is a
CIS white male he is the CIS white male
School Board member was supported by the
Upper Moreland Democrats when he ran in
2019 the father of three children
attended Penn State and received a
bachelor's degree in mechanical
engineering in 2005. according to a 2019
candidate questionnaire he holds four
U.S patents and headed design
installation on lines on the new one
World Trade Center
his interest in the school board grew
when one of his children struggled with
school and was having a very bad
experience he was able to get the IEP
special education resources that his son
needed his goal in running for offices
were was to improve access to special
services for students Okay so
very qualified person is the point and
yet the school board
um voted against making this individual
the president of the board because yeah
all that might be true he's got all
those qualifications
but he has committed the on the
unpardonable sin of being a quote CIS
white male so let's listen to that clip
I believe that Mr delaya would make an
excellent president
however I feel that electing
the only sis white male on this board
president of this District
sends the wrong message
to our community
a message that is contrary to what we as
a board have been trying to accomplish
I think that it's important that we
practice what we preach
and that
our words have strength when they are
spoken
whether we speak them from the
neighborhood sidewalks or from behind
these tables
Mrs stainback has done an exemplary job
as president these last few months
and the strength of her performance has
earned her my vote tonight
so all of that
they can never be
they go almost to the precipice of being
somewhat honest about their intentions
and then they always pull back at the
end because she said all she said all of
that about well he's a CIS white male
and so we can't vote for him and and
then at the very end after explaining
that at the very end she says well I
voted for this other person because of
the strength of her performance no
that's not why you just said
you just you just admitted that you're
voting for this other person because of
her demographics and her identity gonna
have to do with her performance
and by the way this uh this this CIS
thing you know you want to talk about
symbolic gestures that are meant to
Signal your Ascent to LGBT Dogma uh
that's another one using the term sis
and they're being used by a woman who I
don't know she looks she's in her 40s or
50s at least
which which just tells me that she was
she's gone the majority of her life
never using that that term sis
and just over the last couple of years I
started injecting it into our vocabulary
and what is CIS suppose when you say
someone's a CIS white male that's
supposed to you know Assist as someone
who is not transgender who identifies as
their actual biological gender
the whole point of calling someone says
is to is to make it seem like being a
just being a normal man who sees
yourself as a man making it seem like
that's just one potential variation
you know there are many variations on
being a man and sis is just one of them
and there's also trans and there's
there's non-binary
even by using the term CIS
you're basically taking everyone that's
just that's a way of taking it's like
this forced baptism of of everyone
and in the end you force everyone under
the LGBT umbrella
because that is an LGBT term
um
and all of that to say that they can't
vote for this guy because of his because
of his race and his sexuality
she just goes to show once again that we
talked about marginalized groups well in
reality
uh the most marginalized group in
America
heterosexual white males there's just no
way around it and you know the only
thing whenever you make a claim like
this the only thing left can do in
response is just scoff at it but that's
ridiculous white males but they can't
explain why you're wrong
because they know of course you're right
and they know that you take that clip
and you have her explaining
why they can't make someone's School
Board president
um
because of their identity and make it
any identity other than straight white
male
and this is a national Scandal everyone
on that school board is getting fired
and they're probably going to be
criminally prosecuted
can you imagine if it was uh if it was
the exact same conversation and except
instead she said well you know the Leah
is uh unfortunately he's a he's a gay
black man very qualified but he's a gay
black man so it would send the wrong
message to make a gay black man the
president's school board if she said
that she's going to prison for that
she's going she's actually that's a hate
crime she's going to jail
the only group you could possibly get
away with saying that about would be
straight women
all right
and you also see the reverse happening
here right well so we talked about LGBT
you have their percentage in the
population which is still quite small
although it's growing all the while
because they're recruiting and
indoctrinating children into this cult
but um still it's still a a small
minority of the population you can you
compare their percentage to the the
amount of representation and coddling
and celebration that happens in the
culture it's wildly out of balance
and it's the reverse for straight white
men there's a lot of straight white men
in the country but um increasingly you
don't see them in the commercials you
don't see them in shows you know like
you know they're certainly not
celebrated you're not allowed to do that
you are not allowed to express any
specific appreciation for you're not
allowed to say you know I appreciate
everything that straight white men are
doing for our culture you're not allowed
to say that you cannot say it
I mean I'm saying it but
if you care about having any kind of
mainstream approval acceptance you can't
say it
all right what else we got here I wanted
to play this for you too
here's a teacher explaining why
parents should just shut up and let the
school system sexually indoctrinate
their children here's what she says
I have a thought now I know the trolls
are going to be like oh she should have
stopped there but I'm not gonna do that
so there's a lot of controversy about
whether or not sex education health
education relationships gender all that
stuff should be taught in the classroom
here's what I think
you you as in parents send their kids to
school to learn math Reading Writing
history
science from a professional right
but in the same token a lot of people
who do that
also think that they're experts in
sexuality education because they've had
kids
with all due respect just because you
had kids does not mean that you are a
sexuality education expert it does not
mean you are an expert in sex it does
not mean you are an expert in the body
it does not mean you are an expert in
gender it does not mean you are an
expert in relationships
so the same way that we're sending our
kids to school to learn these skills
these life skills like math and
quadratic equations and calculus and
whatever else from a professional we
also need to be ensuring that our
students are learning information about
their health about identity about very
complex issues from a professional
I mean like it makes sense it makes
sense
okay well if you say it makes sense then
that's but that's that is an argument
that I just cannot uh she's she's
that's it it makes sense
they need to learn from like a
professional it makes sense
well okay if you say so
of course it doesn't make sense at all
it doesn't make sense on multiple levels
um the first being you know
even if the school is staffed with
experts on sexuality whatever the hell
that means that still would not make it
you still have not explained why it's
appropriate
why the school is a place for those
kinds of conversations
if there could be something such as a
human sexuality expert
um you still have not explained
why we're putting them in schools
and
how it could possibly be appropriate to
have those conversations with an
eight-year-old
because it's not school's not the place
for that
just because the kids are there
it doesn't mean that you are justified
in uh just talking to them about
whatever you want to talk to them about
but then also
um teachers are not experts in these
subjects
you don't need to be on any you don't
need to be a subject matter expert on
any subject to teach you in a public
school system you don't
like the people that are teaching
mathematics to to sixth graders these
are not these are not expert
mathematicians
and the you know reality is that if if
they were they probably wouldn't you
know it's like it's a cliche but those
who can't do teach and there's like some
truth to that
it's not always the case
but oftentimes it is you know if you're
an actual scientific expert you're
probably not teaching science in third
grade
and I get a lot of respect for people to
teach science at third grade but it's
not that you're not a you're not a
scientific genius necessarily just
because you're doing that
and that's especially the case when it
comes to uh sexuality
there's not experts in these subjects
again even if they were wildly
inappropriate
grotesque
abusive to be having these conversations
to little kids
with little kids in the in a school
system
but they're also not experts in that
just the fact this is something maybe
the left doesn't understand
just because you're a a deviant you're
you're like a sex obsessed deviant
and you have lots of different kinds of
sexual encounters it doesn't make you a
sexuality expert
because I think it's quite the opposite
because you're so consumed by your own
deviancy your own perverse desires your
own fetishes that you couldn't possibly
be an expert you can't think objectively
about this you're just you're just
you're uh
you're consumed by it mentally and
spiritually
again certainly not an expert all right
let's get to the comment
sections
it may be the season of giving but
you've already given enough to your
internet service provider if you haven't
been using expressvpn every time you go
online when you go online without
expressvpn your provider like ATT or
Verizon whoever it is can see every
single website that you visit and
they're legally allowed to sell your
browsing history to third-party
advertisers for massive profits stop
giving away free information to your
internet service provider and start
using expressvpn today expressvpn
encrypts and reroutes 100 of your
network data through their secure
servers so your provider can't see a
thing it sounds complicated but
expressvpn is actually incredibly easy
to use just fire up the app on whatever
device you're using phone laptop
whatever it is and tap one button to
connect and that's all you got to do
you've given enough to your ISP this
year take back your internet privacy
today with the number one rated VPN by
tech radar and Mashable visit
expressvpn.com Walsh you get three extra
months of expressvpn for free that's exp
resvpn.com Walsh to get an extra three
months free
expressvpn.com Welsh
all right you know one of the one of the
good things about having kids is uh is
the key is it really they do keep you
humble and it's always a nice ego check
so it took uh took the family to here
Nashville it's the Gaylord Opryland uh
Resort and they they do um
they have this whole winter Christmas
Wonderland thing they do every single
year and you go and there's like
different ice you know different
uh winter related activities including
ice skating so I went there
uh I think I've gone ice skating maybe
twice in my life and uh but in this case
you know the kids wanted to go ice
skating and they didn't want to be out
on the ice alone my wife obviously can't
go because she's pregnant so I said okay
I'll go I'll go out there put the ice
skates on I'll go out and skate with you
guys and I did
and I I didn't fall
I was I actually thought I did very well
you know I was proud of myself I was
skating around with the kids and I
thought like I'm pretty good at this I'm
actually a natural I might get into
hockey or something this is wow I am
good at this and then on my way on the
way home
um and I was still you know thinking
about it what a good skater I am my son
says to me because my youngest son who
didn't want to go skating so he was
sitting with my wife and like watching
us
and uh he says daddy you looked funny
out there you look like a penguin out on
the ice
I said oh thanks because you were
waddling yeah thanks
you looked really funny I got it thank
you
so I thought I looked great but
apparently I was humiliating myself the
whole time jokes on you though because
penguins are very gifted on the ice so I
take that as a compliment
um
this from lil one says I'm a black woman
and I think it's Ultra ridiculous that
they traded a gay weed smoker for a
Russian armed dealer arms dealer in the
middle of a Russian war
that is ridiculous and that's you know
you don't need to be any particular
identity to see the absurdity of this
Laura and the Wolf says the issue is not
that we are treating weird as normal
it's that we're treating sin as virtue
yeah I think I don't think has to be
either or Lauren I think it's a false
choice I think it's I think the issue is
both
yeah we are treating sin as virtue
and when we talk about virtue signaling
that's why I've never I used the phrase
because we all kind of know what it
means what we're referring to but uh
it's
virtue signal is actually vice versa
signaling it's it's it's sin signaling
the things that are being signaled are
never actually virtues
so that is the problem in the culture
but it is all it is also the the
we have this attack on normalcy
we're conditioning people especially
kids to believe that normal
doesn't exist there's no such thing as
normal
or even that normal is bad you don't
want to be normal
um
and so I think both are happening
let's see summer says am I the only one
who has become
increasingly more frustrated every time
someone says that she Brittany Greiner
was wrongfully detained she broke the
law and got caught what am I missing
yeah she wasn't wrongfully detained I
mean the the sentence of whatever I
forget what the sentence was supposed to
be but many years in you know forced a
forced labor camp for having a vape
cartridge I think we can agree that
that's an overly harsh and I'm all about
Law and Order uh I don't think I would
advocate for for that in this country
now I do advocate for uh for labor camps
for prisoners I think we should go back
to that but uh I don't think I'd give
you 10 years in of forced labor because
he had a vape cartridge
but she did break
the law and she was detained for that
the same way that any of us would be
including by the way in in American
airports
if you try to go through an American
airport with with drug paraphernalia
you're going to get arrested for that
you get arrested for a lot less than
that in American Airport
so I think you're right uh Sam says hi
Matt
last week A co-worker actually confided
in me that his two children are
experiencing a lot of anxiety about the
climate crisis first time I've ever
encountered that level of wokeness in
the wild
apparently it's not all just on Twitter
that's it is absolutely not just on
Twitter just like with the pronouns it's
uh some of this stuff might in some ways
you know social media is a a vector for
this
um
this is how it spreads but it is out in
society as well
including for that for uh you know kids
having climate anxiety
which will never fail to infuriate me
when I hear about that
because there's kids are not
coming up with that on their own okay a
child is not going to walk outside in
the summertime and just on his own come
up with this idea that well this signals
that the ice caps are going to melt
we're all going to drown
he has to be told that so we are we are
giving this anxiety to Children which by
the way even if it was true
that we're on the verge of planetary
extinction because of climate change
which it isn't but even if it was
it would still be unthinkable
to put that on a child
what's he going to do with that
aside from
be plagued by anxiety with apparently
the very few years we all have left
well it was a big year for me personally
I made my first TV appearance on Dr Phil
which led up to the release of my
documentary what is a woman that exposed
the effects of corrosive gender ideology
also held the rally to end child
mutilation which is leading to very real
actions on the part of Tennessee
legislators all this was accomplished
despite the wicked forces that are
trying to silence me and all of us
here's daily wire and all of this was
accomplished largely in part because of
those of you who joined the fight and I
thank you for that but we need more
support this holiday season you can save
30 percent on new daily wire plus annual
memberships and gift memberships when
you use code holiday at checkout if
you're already a member well thank you
for that and if you're not yet a member
now is the time to join uh look 2022 was
huge but I have much more planned in the
future that you'd not go on a miss so go
to dailywire.com Walsh use code holiday
at checkout to get 30 off new daily wire
plus memberships that's dailywire.com
Walsh today now let's get to our daily
cancellation
bye-bye
now this may surprise you but I'm going
to disagree with the majority opinion
about something I don't think of myself
as a contrarian contrary to what most
people say about me but on this I must
dissent a manager in Olive Garden in
Kansas has been fired after sending an
angry email to employees telling them
that they may not call out of work for
any reason and if they claim that their
dog died as an excuse for coming to work
they have to bring the dead dog in as
proof now the manager whose name has not
been published thankfully was fired and
most people have applauded the decision
after the email went viral but I'm on
the manager side of this and I'll
explain why but first here's the story
from a local CBS affiliate it says a
Johnson County restaurant manager sent a
harsh message to employees about taking
time off and was subsequently fired in
Olive Garden media relations
representative confirmed to KCTV5 a
manager at the restaurant on 95th Street
sent the below message to staffers and
here is the message in full this is what
it says quote our call-offs are
occurring at a staggering rate from now
on if you call off you might as well go
out and look for another job we are no
longer tolerating any excuse for calling
off if you're sick you need to come
prove it to us if your dog died you need
to bring him in and prove it to us if
it's a family emergency and you can't
say too bad go work somewhere else if
you only want morning shifts too bad go
work at a bank if anyone from here on
out calls out more than once in the next
30 days you will not have a job
do you know in my 11 and a half years at
Darden how many times I called off zero
I came in sick I got in a wreck
literally on my way to work one time
airbags went off and my car was totaled
but you know what I made it there on
time there are no excuses us
collectively as a management team have
had enough if you don't want to work
here don't it's as simple as that if
you're here and want and want to work
then work no more complaining about not
being cut or not being able to leave
early if you're in the restaurant
business do you think I I want to be
here until midnight on Friday and
Saturday no I'd much rather be at home
with my husband and dog going to the
movies or seeing family but I don't I'm
dedicated to being here as should you no
more excuses or complaints I hope you
choose to continue to work here and I
think we the management make it as easy
as we can on y'all thank you for your
time and thank you yeah to those who
come and work every day to work every
day and work hard I wish they were more
like you okay
as a message Olive Garden announced that
it had parted ways with the manager
after uh this was released it was a
predictable decision but the wrong one
now
obviously there's some hyperbole there
you shouldn't actually bring a dead dog
into a restaurant this is Olive Garden
not Panda Express for God's sake and of
course it's conceivable that a person
could have a reason to call out more
than once in a 30-day period I rarely
call in sick to work but I I missed an
entire week a entire week a few months
ago after I lost my voice not a lot I
can do without a voice though even then
I still dragged myself to work and I
recorded a segment in subtitles that's
how committed I am to my job
or it's how committed I am to trolling
you decide perhaps there's not much
difference between the two at any rate
the point is that there there is reason
to object to this manager's message to
employees if you insist on taking it
absolutely literally
but a more charitable interpretation is
that this person is trying to run a
restaurant and yet is sabotaged every
step of the way by spoiled entitled
brats who want a paycheck but don't want
to put the work in to earnings
and these are frustrations shared by a
great many managers in the restaurant
and retail space and other industry
Industries call outs and no shows are at
an all-time high
and it's not because everyone's dogs are
dying all of a sudden it's not because
there's a record number of family
emergencies
uh if it's a if it's a medical emergency
driving this problem the medical
emergency is a severe allergy to hard
work I think is the that's the real
epidemic happening here this is an
Affliction which has spread across an
entire generation and Beyond
and the people who are trying
desperately to keep our economy afloat
by keeping these businesses open
they're fed up and they're Furious and
they should be
if I was in charge of Olive Garden I
wouldn't fire that manager I'd give them
I I give him a raise and a promotion
because this is exactly the no-nonsense
get your crap together attitude that we
need
now of course there is another side to
the story I made a condensed version of
the point I just articulated on Twitter
over the weekend and Lauren Southern
responded disagreeing with me saying
quote people are fed up working jobs
with no upward Mobility no living wage
thanks to inflation and no real benefit
to their Community multinational
corporations workers don't care anymore
because a manager that asks you to bring
your dead dog in clearly doesn't care
about them either now Lauren and I went
back and forth several times and um
although this breaks the rules of
arguments on the internet we still
respect it and appreciate each other by
the end of it
um I've been a fan of Lawrence for a
long time and still him and she raises
an important Point here which which I
don't fundamentally disagree with it's
true that many people are disillusioned
and demoralized and they have no hope
they're dropping out of a system that
they feel is rigged against them so
she's right about that and I made a
similar point or at least a related
point in one of my monologues last week
it's an important aspect of this problem
and and it's important that we talk
about it but there are other realities
which also must be acknowledged
because this is not a simple matter of
the working class rising up against
their wealthy oppressors
the people left holding the bag here
such as managers at Olive Garden they're
a work in class too
and it's worth sticking up for them
and and on that note a few points first
many of the workers who are giving up
and throwing in the towel Are Young
okay like late teens early 20s
these are not people who've been
grinding it out for years and years and
have finally become exhausted by it
most of the shift workers at Olive
Garden they are they're not going to be
people in their 50s who've been slaving
away for decades only to have their
opportunities for greater success stolen
away by various misfortunes and
calamities out of their control there
may certainly be some people in that
category but a greater number are young
adults in college or just out of college
uh or who never went to college but are
around that same age and if you're in
this this demographic and you've already
stopped trying
that's a whole lot less understandable
because you never started trying you
can't be fed up with something that
you've never even done
you're in your early 20s how do you
think life is supposed to go for you at
that age do you think you're supposed to
enter adulthood and immediately be
rewarded with the kind of wealth and
Fortune and job security that most
people work decades to attain
what what did you expect working at
Olive Garden sucks
of course it does
of course it does no one ever said it
doesn't there's no version of working in
Olive Garden that won't suck
but you got to start somewhere you got
to pay your dues you have to work your
way towards whatever it is you want it's
it's not going to be handed to a very
small fraction of human beings in the
history of the world have been born so
wealthy that they never have to work for
anything in their lives
but if you like me are not in that
category then there is no option but to
build for yourself whatever kind of life
you want
or rather there is no other respectable
honorable option
unfortunately our society does provide
the option of coasting by living off of
the very system you pretend to oppose
while profiting from the work done by
others and as I've often preached you
know life requires work life is work
I wish it wasn't that way
but it is
the only question is whether you will do
the work necessary to to sustain your
own existence or if you'll find a way to
force someone else to do it for you
door number two was never available to
most humans who have lived on the planet
but it is available for us
okay because as it turns out the system
that really controls things this is what
they want
they want you to be a lazy good for
nothing just coasting through life with
no ambition no no real desires no plan
nothing
they want you to be satisfied with being
merely uh fed and distracted
that's what they want
so they've made this option available to
us
now you think you could protest that
system by doing exactly what they want
by becoming the sort of person they want
you to be which is like a non-person a
non-entity just a big nothing
who does nothing and and it contributes
nothing at all to the world
so if you walk through that door
you will be entering into a life of mere
existence mere satiation
you will not find success you will not
find dignity you will not find joy
and most of all if you take door number
two you cannot pretend that you're above
it all that you're fed up with the grind
that you found a more enlightened way to
live
that's not the case because you're still
very much dependent on those who are in
The Grind
those who are doing what you will not do
and are now forced to work even harder
just to subsidize you
you notice that there's employees at the
Olive Garden don't want to put the work
in
they still want the paycheck right
but
in order to have a paycheck this this
restaurant needs to stay open needs to
exist
and they don't want to contribute much
to making that happen
but they need someone to do it
right they need they need enough people
there at Olive Garden to keep that damn
place open so they can keep keep getting
the paycheck they want
so they are just they are just uh
handing off all of those
responsibilities to someone else having
someone else do it for him
someone else who is also working class
someone else who was also not wealthy
they're not passing it off to the CEO of
Olive Garden you're passing it off to
the other to just whoever there at Olive
Garden to whatever Patsy you can find to
do the work that you won't do
because in the end you must work you
don't have to like it
you don't have to think it's fair
but if you wish to keep your dignity
and the moral High ground or any moral
ground at all
there is no other option
some people understand this like the
Olive Garden manager and they live
accordingly
and so often the ones who do the work
only get insult to add to injury time
and time again
they become the bad guy they're doing
everything
they're the only reason that these good
for nothings have a freaking paycheck to
begin with and they end up the bad guys
no
not in this segment anyway that's why it
is not the Olive Garden manager who was
canceled but the lazy employees with
their fake dead dogs and made up sick
family members they are the ones who are
today canceled
and I'll do it for this portion of the
shows move over to the members block
thanks for uh hope to see you there if
not talk to you tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
foreign
[Music]